before we get out of here I just want to
talk about James Corden has officially
issued an apology who's no longer banned
from Balthazar oh thank God okay this is
I know I was gonna do oh my God I know
this is difficult Mark Mark was
babysitting his kids when we were out
there in Palm Springs yeah oh yeah do
you know what I mean he's very good
friends with he was teaching we teach
him soccer we had a great time soccer
there's a lot of James Corden slander
people are saying he's a bad guy people
are saying he's rude he was saying he's
not a good singer in a car great guy
those things are false [ __ ] he was
very nice to me very nice except for
when I tried to celebrate with this kid
and I tackled him and he was like all
right really yeah that was weird that
was weird a little weird yeah you're
talking about I played soccer with James
Corden and his children yep you did yeah
and it was super fun he was a great guy
oh and all these people are saying he's
mean and bad to wait staff I think is uh
he could run no he wasn't doing much
running he was playing goalie a lot but
I assume yeah good guy though yeah I
would go for goalie too yeah but uh he
was banned from Balthazar for like a few
days because he got into it with a
waiter yeah
you know my man
do you know James Corden personally yeah
no you guys haven't interacted we've
interacted when Mark was playing soccer
because I always hear he's I've heard
this before any of this came out I heard
he was like a big phony and that
actually this is like seven eight years
ago somebody wrote on his show and
they're like oh he seems so nice and he
was like he's like Ellen and this before
you know anything about Ellen too and I
was like both of them ain't [ __ ] and I
found out both of them are apparently
mean yeah it's just kind of wacked to me
that he apologized over Balthazar
yeah balthazar's fire though man
you know Balthazar I know it yeah yeah
you don't like it that much I think it's
about to get banned bro you're about to
get yeah yeah yeah be get very careful
right now but what's up he apparently
didn't ask me anything years ago and
then it quickly became a bunch of shitty
stories about him just back to back to
back that he wouldn't acknowledge but no
apologies for any of that no nothing for
that it's like a legendary thing now
that Reddit page that ama never
acknowledge it and then Balthazar
Advance him and he's like I got it
please please forgive me it's like
that's what he cares about man this is
apparently what happened this is the
thing that you care about I think as
soon as you figure out what he did wrong
you are gonna completely flip all right
let's just find out so in June James
Corden was here on table 61 although
this is diabolical it happens very
occasionally in all restaurants after
eating his main course Gordon showed the
hair to Balthazar manager G he was very
apologetic Gordon was extremely nasty
and said get us another round of drinks
this second and also take care of all of
our drinks so far this way I write any
nasty reviews in Yelp or anything like
that right I think this way I won't
write any Nest reviews into Yelp hey
James Corden why you want to Yelp
I mean why did you just tweet as James
yeah you read a yell preview and you're
like James Corden says this really it's
not the real oh yeah g chord and four
two six five says yeah what a [ __ ]
and then apparently power this happened
in October him and his wife go out for
brunch he asked for a table outside
brunch Major D says yeah here we go 301
James Corden wife ordered an egg yolk
omelette with gruyere cheese and salad a
few minutes later they received the food
James called the server MK and told her
there was a little bit of egg white
mixed with the egg yolk that's an issue
MK informed the floor manager G the
kitchen remade the dish but
unfortunately sent it with home fries
instead of salad that's when James
Corden began yelling like crazy the
server you can't do your job you can't
do your job maybe I should go to the
kitchen and cook The Omelette myself MK
was very apologetic and brought you over
to the table return the dish yeah James
Corden so no I'm not oh really no I'm
not I sound like
listen it's frustrating they get it
wrong but they get it wrong yeah I'm
gonna go to the kitchen do it just no
you not you have a kitchen dummy yeah
you could have done that at home
omelette that's [ __ ] disgusting
impossible to get no egg white in an egg
yolk omelet it's literally impossible no
not really the yolk has egg white on it
it's got tiny white a little bit it has
to it's sitting in the white even if you
scoop the whole thing out there's no way
to shave every single it's gonna be a
little bit on it
think about the yolk who gets disgusted
by by who wants only yolk yeah I've
never heard that that's crazy
yeah I want all the fat none of the
Protein that's crazy anyway yeah that's
crazy you can't speak to a waiter like
that yeah uh-uh there's a little bit of
egg white in The Omelette I'm so that's
crazy yeah and his whole personality is
built on being what a sweet guy is and
we're just singing get in the [ __ ]
car doing karaoke also you're a guest
immigrant
don't they call that the clown Visa oh
no no your [ __ ] place though James
there's one circus that has Visa that
all the comics
all I'm trying to say is Yo treat
Balthazar with respect that's an
American New York institution
let's go right now let's go right now
I'm going about this out right now how
much are we gonna tip not only am I
gonna tip extra I'm ordering white in
the yolk extra for him is 20 yeah what's
funny is that I'd want to hurt you
you [ __ ] losers wow
I don't feel comfortable doing that I'll
give it to charity what I would give
that money to charity how much money I
give a hundred dollars you're a
billionaire you're giving a hundred
dollars a charity give me a billion
dollars
I would give a hundred dollars to uh the
floods in your home country yeah
I'm awesome no
um but no I think James Court is wrong I
tip more than all of you and suck dick
that's it y'all don't even order apps